Ein neuer Blick auf die alten Meister:
Die Ausstellung „Giganten der Renaissance“
zeigt die bekanntesten Werke
von Raffael, Michelangelo und
Leonardo Da Vinci
– digitalisiert, animiert und mit Musik
unterlegt.
Das Kunstkraftwerk Leipzig arbeitet
bei dem Projekt
mit dem Italiener Gianfranco Iannuzzi
zusammen,
ein weltweit bekannter Videokünstler.
Die Renaissance war damals sehr modern
und hat die Welt der Kunst
verjüngt und verändert.
Sie bewegte sich weg von den
religiösen Motiven, hin zu immer mehr
weltlichen Darstellungen.
Und so konnte auch die Freskenmalerei
in die Architektur einfließen,
das wäre sonst nicht möglich gewesen.
Unsere Installation ist eine Hommage an
diese große Bewegung der Kunst.
Um die Multimediashow einem breiten
Publikum zugänglich zu machen,
bedient er sich der immersiven Kunst.
Dabei taucht der Betrachter
mittels 24 Beamer in
die acht Meter hohen Video-Projektionen ein.
So werden selbst die kleinsten
Pinselstriche sichtbar.
Ich denke, dass das Zusammenspiel von
Video und Klang jetzt noch etwas Neues ist,
so wie es die Fotografie und das Kino auch
mal war.
Auch sie haben sich weiterentwickelt und
unsere Wahrnehmung verändert.
Sie ist nun nicht mehr nur visuell, sondern
virtuell und auditiv.
Von Beginn an spielt auch die Musik eine
zentrale Rolle.
Der Soundkünstler Luca Longobardi wählt die
Stücke aus und arrangiert sie neu.
Ich arbeite besonders viel digital,
also am Computer,
aber ich arbeite auch mit Musikern
zusammen, die live spielen.
So gibt es in der Ausstellung ein Stück von
mir,
das ich ursprünglich für ein Orchester
geschrieben habe.
Für die Installation aber spielen nur ein
einziges Streichquartett
und ein digitales Orchester zusammen.
Am Ende hört es sich an, als ob ein echtes
Orchester live in einer Kirche spielt.
Die Renaissance im 15. und 16. Jahrhundert
war eine bahnbrechende Epoche.
Bis heute hat sie den Blick des Menschen auf
sich und die Welt nachhaltig verändert.
Dazu haben auch die Werke von Raffael,
Michelangelo
und besonders Leonardo Da Vinci
beigetragen.
Er gilt als einer der berühmtesten
Universalgelehrten aller Zeiten.
Leonardo war immer ein Visionär.
Er sah Dinge voraus, die einige Jahre nach
ihm erfunden wurden.
Ich denke, wenn er
in der heutigen Zeit leben würde,
hätte er bestimmt viele Erfindungen
digital entworfen.
Vielleicht hätte er in diesem Raum ein neues
holografisches Fluggerät projiziert.
Uraufgeführt wurde die Ausstellung
in Frankreich.
Das Ambiente wurde für Leipzig
neu abgestimmt.
Dieses Spektakel bewegt mich regelrecht.
Also, an manchen Stellen
bin ich zu Tränen gerührt
und mich hat es wirklich ergriffen.
Das ist auch die Absicht dieser Künstler.
Sie wollen nicht mehr,
dass man sich einfach
nur so das Gemälde anschaut, sondern eine
andere Art der Begegnung herstellt.
Und das ist, was mich angeht, gelungen.
Ich bin begeistert.
Immersive Kunst als kollektive Erfahrung –
noch bis Ende 2019 können Besucher in die
weltbekannten Kunstwerke eintauchen.